en 2023 près de 4 millions de Françaises
sont victimes de précarité menstruelle
donc lorsqu'une femme ne peut pas se
fournir en protection hygiénique par
manque tout simplement de moyens ce
chiffre là c'est un chiffre qui est
important c'est quasiment deux fois plus
qu'en 2021 donc on voit que c'est un
problème qui prend de
l'ampleur en mars il me semble que votre
gouvernement avait annoncé le remse le
remboursement pardon des protections
périodiques réutilisables pour les moins
de 25 ans ouais ma question là-dessus
est très simple est-ce que c'est
toujours d'actualité et si c'est
toujours d'actualité quelle forme ça va
prendre pour pour ses étudiantes
l'engagement sera tenu et sur les
protections hygiéniques réutilisables
pour les moins de 25 ans 25 ans compris
elles seront elles seront remboursées en
2024 en pharmacie et en 2025 sur une
plateforme en ligne dédiée qui permettra
d'acheter ces ces protectionsès cl